Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
Io mi sento un uomo fortunato.
Perché il mio lavoro di compositore,
oltre a farmi girare il mondo
e a farmi incontrare persone
che vengono ad ascoltare la musica,
mi permette di confrontarmi.
E spesso, queste persone
sono amanti della musica, o musicisti,
oppure gente specializzata:
altri compositori.
Non ho però la fortuna di stare di fronte
a un pubblico come voi,
ricco di diversità.
Per cui, non vi nascondo
che mi sento giustamente emozionato.
Però sono qui, ora, con voi
e qualcosa devo fare.
Per cui, partirei subito con una domanda.
[Qual è l'opera lirica
più corta della Storia?]
La creatività, intesa
come moto esclusivamente umano,
non sempre produce artisti.
Perché per poter intraprendere
un percorso artistico,
oltre al talento - e qui non c'è dubbio -
oltre allo studio e all'esperienza,
necessita anche di un atto di coscienza.
Coscienza intesa come consapevolezza:
la consapevolezza che un gesto,
o un'azione, provocano un'emozione.
Infatti, se ci confrontiamo
con gli animali,
capiamo subito che loro utilizzano
la loro intelligenza, il loro istinto,
per colmare i loro bisogni primari:
mangiare;
riprodursi, giustamente;
rifugio.
Difficilmente, però, possiamo dire
che il loro livello
di coscienza sia così alto
da poter permettere loro
di fare un'opera d'arte.
Altrimenti, significherebbe
che il loro livello evolutivo
è paritario quanto meno
a quello dell'essere umano.
Manca ancora un gradino,
per fare la differenza:
e quella differenza, cioè l'arte,
per il momento riusciamo a farla solo noi.
Ma che cosa significa, per l'essere umano,
andare in uno stato artistico?
C'è forse bisogno di un momento
di perdizione di sé stessi,
di delirio artistico o meglio poetico?
Platone diceva che il delirio poetico
è ispirato dalle Muse.
"Chi arriva alle soglie della poesia
senza il delirio delle Muse,
convinto che la sola abilità
lo renda poeta,
sarà un poeta incompiuto
e la poesia del Savio sarà offuscata
da quella dei poeti in delirio.
Non è per la loro arte
che i poeti compongono le opere,
ma per il Dio che si impossessa di loro.
Essi possono poetare
se ispirati e invasati dalla divinità,
che fa loro superare
l'intelletto e la tecnica poetica
e fa loro attingere alla sfera
della irrazionalità lirica".
Irrazionalità lirica:
due parole in completa contrapposizione.
L'irrazionalità è qualcosa di fugace,
istantaneo, buttato lì, non pensato;
la lirica è una forma,
un contenitore, un pensiero.
Platone ci suggerisce, forse,
che il delirio delle Muse
sia un modo per dimenticare
ciò che abbiamo studiato, e imparato,
e andare oltre?
Come si può essere
liricamente irrazionali?
Può essere che il delirio artistico
sia un modo per tornare
a uno stato animale?
Fra parentesi:
vi siete mai sentiti osservati,
e voltandovi di scatto
avete visto qualcuno che vi osservava?
Questo può essere uno stato animale.
Ricapitolando,
può essere che il delirio artistico
sia un modo per tornare
ad uno stato animale,
per colmare un bisogno primario?
Cioè aggiungere, a quella lista
di bisogni primari,
qualcosa che può fare la differenza
tra esseri animali e esseri umani,
in senso emotivo.
Cioè provare dei sentimenti
che vanno oltre il dovuto,
per raggiungere qualcosa
che può fare la differenza: l'arte.
Esempi:
emozionarsi di fronte a un suono;
emozionarsi di fronte a un colore.
A quanti di noi è successo?
Questa necessità, questo bisogno,
è qualcosa a cui l'uomo
non può più fare a meno.
Della bellezza dell'arte.
È una sorta di sesto senso,
che è proprio dell'essere senziente,
cioè dell'essere che pensa,
che è consapevole.
Avete mai dimenticato
la pentola sul fuoco,
o siete passati con il rosso,
perché rapiti da un'idea?
Alzate le mani, non abbiate paura:
ci sono solo 300.000 telecamere.
Vi vede mezzo mondo.
(Risate)
Mi fa piacere, anch'io l'ho fatto.
Come ho detto all'inizio,
non pensavo di stare di fronte
a un pubblico come voi,
di potenziali piromani.
Ma va bene così.
Vi è mai capitato di osservare
una vostra poesia o un vostro dipinto
e dire: ma l'ho fatto io?
Vi hanno già scoperto,
quindi alzate le mani
un'altra volta, se volete.
Grazie, professor Berrino.
Molto gentile.
Dove eravate, in quel momento?
Cosa eravate, in quel momento?
Può essere che in quel momento
si sia raggiunto uno stato animale,
uno stato primario
con tutti i sensi accesi,
pronti a carpire ogni singola emozione
e ogni singola intuizione
per trasformare un'idea
in un percorso artistico?
Questo [stato di] trance artistico
è quello che fa la differenza.
L'intuizione divina,
l'irrazionalità lirica
di cui il buon Platone parlava,
è forse un modo per tornare
ad uno stato animale,
ma con coscienza?
La parola cosciente,
in latino "cosciens entis",
significa "essere consapevole".
A me andrebbe, ora,
di fare un piccolo gioco con voi
per vedere se riusciamo a avere
una coscienza di massa,
per quanto questa massa
sia circoscritta a questa chiesa.
Mi piacerebbe fare un esperimento
ascoltando i suoni intorno a noi.
Ed ora,
ascoltiamo i suoni dentro di noi.
Per essere un artista,
e soddisfare il bisogno dell'arte,
bisogna avere il coraggio
di lasciarsi andare ai sensi animali:
ovviamente, con coscienza.
Ma lasciarsi andare ai sensi animali,
questa profondità, ci porta in alto.
E ci permette di ampliare
la nostra sensibilità.
Ovviamente, per fare tutto ciò
bisogna sorpassare un limite,
che a volte comporta anche dei rischi.
Ma con coraggio,
se ci si lascia andare
in acque sconosciute,
si può intravedere una nuova realtà,
per poi tornare al molo.
Sant'Agostino diceva
che "il presente è tra due punti:
il passato, ovvero la memoria;
il futuro, ovvero l'infinito avvenire".
Luoghi entro due punti non esistono,
per cui cos'è il presente?
Il presente è un'intuizione.
Per noi artisti, questo viaggio onirico
vive dei nostri sogni,
vive dell'introspezione.
Vive della ricerca, tutti i giorni.
Dell'intuizione.
Bisogna lasciarsi andare ai sensi animali,
per poterli dominare con l'intelletto.
In questo modo,
noi possiamo ampliare la nostra visione
e vedere il mondo dei sogni
che prende forma.
Tutti, potenzialmente, siamo artisti:
ma quanti di noi si alzano la notte
perché rapiti da un'intuizione?
Per fare le cose, bisogna farle.
Infatti, si dice che l'arte
ci renda "liberi":
ma "liberi da che cosa?", diceva Mafalda
in una vignetta che avevo letto
qualche tempo fa da qualche parte.
Personalmente, penso che l'arte
ci renda liberi dalle sovrastrutture
che la vita ci mette davanti
tutti i giorni.
Penso che ci renda liberi,
e ci renda sensibili,
cioè con tutti i sensi accesi,
come gli animali.
E infatti, vi racconterò
un fatto personale.
Mi trovavo a Malta.
Ero in vacanza, quindi rilassato.
Era una mattina molto presto:
era un dormiveglia.
E a un certo punto,
sono saltato sul letto.
Perché avevo trovato la parola giusta.
"Taci!"
(Video)
(Applausi)
Grazie.